the chances of you being killed by a
white supremacist are much greater than
Muslim terrorists and white supremacy
inspired by a sign from the civil rights
movement in the 60s an artist put this
up in 2008 but right after President
Obama was elected they took it down now
fast forward eight years and President
Trump was elected which prompted the
gallery to put the sign back up and this
time they say it's going to remain there
indefinitely so how big a threat is
white supremacy I asked Mike German who
spent more than 15 years with the FBI
infiltrating white supremacists and
resigned in protest of what he calls a
dysfunctional and ineffective
counterterrorism strategy I spent about
14 months undercover in the early 90s
with neo-nazi white supremacist groups
and then in the mid to late 90s
undercover with Haiti government militia
groups Ken white supremecy grow in 2017
oh absolutely and and I think it has I
think during the campaign candidate
Trump was very overt in his exploitation
of white supremacist and I think it was
a mutual exploitation Trump
unfortunately also encouraged them in
ways that can be dangerous helped them
grow their membership and help normalize
what they were doing as far as the
racist rhetoric how big a threat are
white supremacists I think we have to
talk about the threat of white supremacy
at two levels there has always been a
threat of violence from white
supremacists and anti-government groups
between 10 and 50 sometimes more deaths
a year from this and that's given that
we don't collect data on a lot of these
crimes I think we have a separate
problem when we talk about white
supremacist ideology influencing policy
and I think that has a potential to do
far more harm particularly when you're
justifying discriminatory treatment in
law enforcement agencies why do you
think there's so much concern about
white supremacy now
Trampas president I don't think Donald
Trump if you sat them down in a room it
really understands white supremacy in
these theologies and ideologies that
support it if you looked back in the end
of 2015 or early 2016 at the white
supremacist bulletin boards and web
sites basically the message that you
would have seen is don't be fooled by
this guy he's not somebody who
understands our movement or is going to
help us if he gets in power and I think
the way that Trump took away the dog
whistle and made the appeals to racism
very overt in the good old days just
does it happen because they used to
treat them very very rough what happened
was all of a sudden mainstream media
were putting microphones in front of
these long-forgotten white supremacists
and these white supremacist groups
anti-government groups they're like
d-list celebrities any news is good news
so anybody putting a microphone in front
of them helps them amplify their message
helps them get introduced to new
audiences so they were happy for that
attention do you think that President
Trump is accelerating the the appeal of
this movement I think he has I think
he's normalized it I think President
Trump has normalized the idea that you
can blame a larger social problem on one
subgroup and that it becomes that simple
immigration in this country is an
enormous issue that requires the deep
understanding of what the social
problems and broader labor issues are
and many other issues with our foreign
policy and why there are refugees and
foreign countries well that's hard if I
say as Donald Trump did that Mexicans
are criminals coming into this country
doing harm and we just need to report
them all the problem will be over that's
a simple solution I can understand I
don't have to study foreign policy I
don't have to study economics president
Trump has now empowered Steve Bannon who
is viewed by many within that Kim
as a leader of white supremacist
ideology if you will and certainly white
nationalist I mean is this semantics
when we say white nationalist all right
and then white supremacist there are
meanings to words and and I think it's
always best to try to be as clear as
possible I mean this concept of this alt
right was an avenue of expanding the
movement beyond just white supremacist
beyond just Theo Nazis into a group of
people who or otherwise angered but have
the same sort of authoritarian impulses
to blame it on some weaker subgroup when
he puts his head on the pillow at night
is having daydreams of the Fourth Reich
or whether he's just manipulating an
audience that that he knows these ideas
appeal to doesn't matter that the effect
is the same you're creating policies
that are doing great damage not just the
individuals but to our society we have a
very diverse society and that diversity
is our strength just last week three men
of Indian descent were shot while they
were watching sports at a bar in Kansas
one was killed their attacker was
yelling at them to quote get out of my
country even here in New York City's
Lower East Side one of the most diverse
neighborhoods in the country a gang of
white supremacists attacked two brothers
right outside this bar and the reason
why well police say that the brothers
were wearing anti-fascist stickers the
Trump administration wants to revamp and
rename the US government program of
countering violent extremism to focus
solely on radical Islamic extremism
changing that terminology at least makes
it clear what the program was the
program was almost entirely during the
Obama administration focused on Muslim
communities I was not aware of any
outreach to churches to ask where Ku
Klux Klan's members lived because
they're Christians are at least claimed
to be that would be totally
inappropriate and none not helpful but
yet they felt perfectly comfortable
going into a mosque
asking where Isis is or al-qaeda without
really understanding that that's not
where these groups operate and pushing
the conversations that we should be
having into the corners makes them more
dangerous what was kind of your takeaway
key things that you think most Americans
would be surprised to know about white
supremacy in America in this day and age
I went in believing this is going to be
something that's just about ignorance
and hate and bigotry but it actually had
very complex philosophies and even
theologies to their viewpoint history is
much longer and White's had had legal
dominance and legal rights above other
races and that was justified through
these political and religious ideologies
and it's only been a short time really
since the end of the civil rights
movement that we're trying this what
they would call an experiment in
multiculturalism and they would argue
that experiment isn't going well and
should be reversed but it's not a matter
of creating a new system they just want
us to go back to the old system
[Music]